[Music]
hello everyone
we are going to start our first chapter
of applied elasticity
now despite the name applied it is still
very much
a mathematical course and all the
applications
as denoted by the word applied will be
through
a mathematical language
uh as a foundation to all that we are
going to do in the subsequent chapters
uh what we are going to study in this
first chapter is some of the
mathematical preliminaries or some of
the
uh some of the utilities which will be
used over and over
again all throughout the subsequent
chapters
now there are two approaches that we can
adopt uh
in approaching this chapter so uh in
covering this chapter so the first
approach
is uh what you will often see in most of
the textbooks
of of any any good elasticity book
and especially if you take up a book of
continuing mechanics you'll see that the
first chapter is almost
always a heavy uh
chapter on tensor algebra intensive
calculus
we could do that that is the first
approach or
uh the second approach is that we
uh we pick out the things which will be
actually necessary for the purpose of
this course
and learn only that okay so because we
we are restricted
in time uh especially uh in this online
mode
the number of restrictions so what we
are going to do is we are going to take
up the second approach of study
so we are going to pick out selectively
only those things
which we will actually require for our
subsequent chapters
and study them properly in this chapter
okay so without
any further ado let us get into the
business of the first chapter on
mathematical
preliminaries
so the first thing that we are going to
discuss is the representation of
vectors and in general tenses in a
number of different ways
so it has been my experience with uh
with previous students
that they face they often face
some difficulty in these different
representations
of while the truth of the matter is
actually that
these various representations are
actually there to
help out the to help out the users
that's us
uh with uh with dealing with the
with some of the more complicated things
so there are a number of different ways
we can use it
uh so so these representations will
will will be applicable in various uh
use case scenarios
so first of all something which you are
all very familiar with
is vectors
okay so the first
way of representing a vector is the is
the
absolutely familiar compact notation uh
maybe this
terminology itself is not familiar to
you but the thing itself
will be familiar to you in compact
notation what we do is
we write the vector simply with this
half arrow
above it or sometimes we also write it
like this with a tilde
in uh at the bottom so that's the
compact notation that's all there is to
it
okay now
when we write like this okay we
understand that
the vector quantity itself uh it is
this is just the representation of the
vector entity itself
uh we are not referring to any
particular coordinate system when we are
writing like this
but uh and you also note that
that the existence of a vector entity
is very much independent of um
of the particular way in which it may be
represented
referred to a coordinate system so this
point will be cleared
in the next way of notation which is the
component notation
so here in this compound notation what
we do is
we write it like in terms of its scalar
components
like this v1 e1 hat
plus v 2 e 2 hat
plus v 3 e 3 hat
now this same vector v
and let me write down this clearly let
me let me note it down clearly here that
this e1 hat and e2 e2 hat and e3 hat
they are the unit vectors along the
coordinate axis of our choice
uh in this particular system which are
the x1
x2 and x3 axis so probably most of you
are familiar with
uh with the more common uh xyz
coordinate system
but here in general we are going to
write it like x1
x2 and x3 coordinate system okay and the
e1 hat e2 hat and e3 hat are
respectively the
unit vectors along those three
coordinate axes
but that is only a choice the x1 x2 x3
our coordinate axis is only a choice
we might as well choose another another
separate coordinate system maybe x1 dash
x2 dash and x3 dash
in that case the unit vectors along the
three coordinate axis would be
e 1 hat dash e 2 hat dash and e 3 hat
dash
and in that coordinate system the same
vector v
here that same vector v refer to a
different coordinate system
would be given by a set of three
separate scalar quantities like v1 dash
v2 dash and v3 dash
so you see here it is the same vector v
that we are talking about but here it is
referred to a different coordinate
system
where the unit vectors of concern are e
1 hat dash
e 2 hat dash and e 3 hat dash
correspondingly
the scalar components have also changed
now the v 1 dash
v 2 dash and v 3 dash okay
so the component wise notation here
and here are completely different but
they refer to the they represent the
same vector quantity
this is an extremely important point to
note now
we may write this in a slightly shorter
fashion
like this so i equal to 1 to 3
summation
v i e i hat
similarly this one can be written as
i equal to one to three
v i dash e i
hat dash okay
so we will come back to why we have
written it like this
little bit later uh for now we continue
with our different representations on
notations and the next thing that we are
going to write is the
matrix representation you can write it
like matrix notation but
i am just writing it like matrix
representation
ok so here we are again going to talk
about the same vector v
fine but now for the purpose of the
matrix representation we'll put this
pair of square brackets around it and
note
that again refer to a particular
coordinate system x1 x2 and x3
it can be represented in an explicit
fashion
in this way which i believe
almost all of you are familiar with so
this is one way of representing it in
matrix form
it could can be another way which is
like in the form
of a of a row so this is like a column
this is a row
this one is correct this one is also
correct okay
now we have to make a choice of either
one of them in order to proceed and we
will stick to that choice so the for the
purpose of our course of applied
elasticity we are going to
stick to this column matrix form choice
okay furthermore you note
that just just like we had a
a particular set of v1 v2 and v3 scalar
components of the vector
here also we have this v1 v2 v3
which means that even in the matrix
representation
we even though we are not writing
explicitly the unit vectors
still we are actually referring to a
particular set of coordinate axes
so if we were referring to another set
of coordinate axes the
matrix representation even in this
column format would have been different
because
these three elements would be instead of
v 1 v 2 v 3 it would have been
v1 dash v2 dash and v3 dash like it was
here okay so the next uh
the next thing that we are going to
discuss uh is the
index notation or representation and
this one is extremely extremely
useful and important for the purpose of
our
course and especially for the whole of
continuum mechanics
and you will see as we progress through
the course how the use of this index
notation
will greatly simplify and shorten
our our our algebra and our
writing system
but there is a little bit of the catch
that when people are first introduced to
the index notation
it can become a little bit confusing
okay but if we adhere to certain rules
of the index notation then it can indeed
become really really easy to use and
very useful to use also
so what we are going to do is we are
first going to write the vector
representation
of the v vector as we have been doing
for the
other notations and we note down that
it is simply written as vi
okay that's it just vi we don't have to
put any summation sign
in front of it we do not have to put an
unit vector here also
okay after it it is just vi
so it is understood
even though i am writing it explicitly
here that i will be equal to 1 2 and 3
that's it that is all that's all there
is to it now uh
what we are going to do next is we are
going to discuss
a few rules of the index notation okay
now uh in keeping with the spirit
of the the utilitarian spirit of
the discussion of our chapter what you
are going to do is we are not going to
go into any formal discussion of these
rules
rather we are going to list out the
rules
which will be actually very much useful
subsequently to us
so some of the some of the useful rules
of
this index notation we should which we
should definitely keep in mind
are as follows
the first rule of index notation is that
we don't have to use any summation sign
no summation sign
or unit vectors
are required
no summation or unit vectors are written
that's the first rule as you have seen
here we we are not using any summation
sign
we are not using any unit vectors in
contrast to
the previous page where you note here in
the compact notation the shortened form
of the contact
compact sorry the component notation we
are using the summation sign and we are
using this kind of unit vector
so that is no longer required in index
notation that is implicitly understood
the next rule
is
is that a
a repeated index
indicates summation all right
so what that basically means is that if
you have something like
if you have if you have something like
let's say a i b
i then this is basically
a1 b1 plus a2 b2
plus a3 b3
okay and you will see uh soon enough
that this kind
of of a repeated index is very much
useful to write the dot product okay so
we'll discuss that subsequently
so another rule is that
a repeated index
is like a dummy index
is like a dummy index
and
it can be replaced
by any other
any other letter so what i mean is
that if you have a thing like a i
b i this is perfectly equal
to a j b j
this is perfectly equal to a p
b p and so on and so forth
you keep on writing as long as you are
repeating the index at the same places
so that's what i
mean the letter i has been replaced by
letter j the letter i has been replaced
by the letter p
it does not make any difference so the
the the moment you see that something is
repeated it is just a dummy index
and its only job is to denote the
summation
okay as uh as noted down in point number
two
okay another very important
rule uh so we'll continue on the next
page is
is that an index
repeated more than once
an index repeated more than once
is
is meaningless
this is very important to note so
something like
uh a i b i c
i okay this is just wrong don't write
don't ever ever write like this
and we'll see uh immediately an
application of this particular rule
in our subsequent discussion so never
ever write
an index mode so never ever repeat an
index more than once
so had it been repeated only once so a
ibi that is fine
but repeated more than once so written
three times it doesn't make any sense
okay and finally
the the number
of free indices
the total number of free indices that
are present in a particular term
denotes the order of that term denotes
the
the order of the tensor of that term
so when we say something like a i
so you see here the i is not repeated
any index which is not repeated is
referred to as a
free index okay so free indices
basically means an
index which is not repeated so uh so
let's say
when we go back to this example
this i here is repeated so i is not a
free index in this particular case but
when we are writing
only one i here there is nothing
repeated here it is a free index
and the number of free indices in this
entire term is one
so the order of the tensor is
tensor of order one
okay which we know uh
is a vector now
at this point i would like to point out
that
uh so students in this particular class
they are coming from various different
backgrounds uh so if some of you uh
are not familiar with uh with the
underlying concepts of
what is a tensor i would highly suggest
you
to take a look at some of my other
lectures
from the undergraduate classes
especially
uh the mechanics of solids class uh
so you'll get some some fairly good
idea about what uh what we mean by the
word
tensor so here at this point i will not
spend any more time on that okay
uh next suppose we have something like
let's say bi
ci so which here you note that
the number of free indices here is how
many
it is zero in number so this is a tensor
of order zero which is nothing
but a scalar quantity and you know this
for a fact because
we according to our previous rule this b
i c i basically means b 1 c 1
plus b 2 c 2 plus b 3 c 3 and that
is indeed a scalar quantity as opposed
to this suppose we have something like
a quantity like a
k
about this so here we have one repeated
index which is the k
and one free index which is the j so
this is again
a tensor
of order
one similarly suppose we write something
like
e l m
that is a tensor
of order
two okay and uh
i believe most of you would be familiar
about the word tensor in the context of
the stress
tensor or the strain tensor both of
which
are tensors of order two
we could keep on giving more and more
examples of this
but uh just uh in order to keep
the things within the context of applied
elasticity i'll just note down that
suppose you have something like
c i j k l
that is as you can guess a tensor
of order four
and this c i j k l will be using in our
subsequent chapter
of the material behavior okay now with
these
indeed in index notation
with these rules of index notation i
believe
we are in a good position to go ahead
with the rest of our discussions of
mathematical preliminaries
and the first thing that we are going to
discuss as a kind of application of all
of this
is to represent of all these rules of
index notation
is how to represent
the the dot product and we will go
forward
subsequently with with bigger and better
things
but we'll continue with that part in the
in the next
lecture thank you